[Applause]
so your friends are having babies in
quarantine
but you found love in quarantine
as a single woman i'm just curious how
it's so weird believe me i'm like still
i still cannot get over the fact that it
happened because
i remember in quarantine i was like cool
so
i'm single now and i can't meet anybody
and i'm like
i guess i'll go on a dating app but i
always said i would never go on a dating
app and then i found myself in a dating
app and i was like i
hate myself so i was like gotta get off
of that
and so i kind of just gave up for a
minute and
i was working on tick tick boom and my
girlfriend was on this zoom meditation
group
weekly and she's like would you want to
hop on i was like of course i love that
they added me to a group text and
everyone's sending like gifts of
themselves
it's like joe jonas and like wilmer
valderrana and so like i sent a gif of
myself
and then there's like a gif in the group
chat
of like a baseball player and he's
sliding onto a base and i thought it was
a joke
so i just responded hot
and then i get on the zoom and i'm like
who is that and i found them and
we started talking and yeah it's wild
that uh
you know we found each other over zoom
wait did you like
slip into his dms did you say on the
group text
like how did you navigate that because
i'm actually asking
as a woman because i think that i'm
still weirdly as much as i'm like
empowered i think i still have that
stigma that like the man is supposed to
do that initial step and i don't even
know if that's the right way to go about
it anymore
i mean i'm such a go-getter i'm like if
i
want something or someone i'm going
after him
like i i fully just slid into his dms
and was like
hey it was nice to meet you um so i
think there is no shame in making the
first move
if you want it why wait for someone else
to give you what you want
well i think i'm going to take your
advice of don't be so old-fashioned
follow through be a woman who is
empowered
both at work and in life and with
friendships as well as romance
exactly go after what you want let them
know
now you were talking about tick tick
boom which i'm so excited about
and you were filming it's lin manuel is
directing
right lin manuel miranda i think the
shakespeare of our times
and andrew garfield's in it tell me
about
it um yeah so i'm a big jonathan larson
fan
i was introduced to his work
when i did rent at the hollywood bowl
did the summer production
played me me fell in love with the world
that jonathan larson
wrote and created um and so
after that i then did rent live played a
different character
got to meet like his family jonathan's
family they were always their sister and
dad and it just felt like i really was
being
integrated into like the legacy that is
jonathan larson
and then i heard about tic take boom and
i was like i
i have to be a part of this movie in
whatever capacity
um and i ended up getting to play a part
where i am one of jonathan larson's
backup vocalist jonathan played by
um andrew garfield and
it's just it's really really special
because
tick tick boom he wrote for himself as a
one-man play
and it's pretty autobiographical and
it just really sets the tone and and
gives you a peek into
what it was like being a struggling
artist in in the 90s
in the lower east side of new york i
can't wait for this
i i truly jonathan larson lin-manuel you
andrew garfield and you got a tattoo to
commemorate the end of it
uh this tattoo it says cages or wings um
because that's one of the lyrics in in
the movie
and it's just it's so beautiful because
he wrote this
in the 90s and the lyrics are so
relevant still to this day and the hook
is cages or wings
which do you prefer ask the birds fear
love baby don't say the answer actions
speak louder than words
and i just think that it's so beautiful
so i needed it on my body
i love that i got a new tattoo yesterday
on the show
which was so fun and
it says home is where we are for
me and my girls but one thing i
always wanted to do as well was
you know go out there in the world as
much as i was
a creative i loved business too and i
love
sharing things and i love being a
curator and now
you have cali water and i'm so excited
about this
will you please tell us about this as i
crack one open
yeah of course i love it i love watching
people trying for the first time it's my
favorite thing ever
oh my gosh this is amazing and it has
prickly pear tell me everything
yeah this is cali water you're drinking
the ginger and lime um
the original flavor is prickly pear and
i was on a road trip through mexico and
there were prickly pear margaritas
everywhere
and being the margarita aficionado that
i am and i was like oh i gotta give this
a try
fell in love and i was like what is this
prickly pear thing i've never really
heard that much about it and i looked it
up and
realized that there have been people for
decades hundreds of years centuries
using prickly pear as like a health
remedy um
so i hit up my friend ollie oliver
trevina and i knew that he's trying to
do a beverage and so i was like i think
that we gotta do this
this prickly pear thing um and worked
really hard to put together the perfect
concoction
so it has so many amazing properties
there
um uh there's so many antioxidants which
is great for your skin um
there's more electrolytes in it than
coconut water
whenever i'm hungover i drink them
whenever
i am trying to like make a cocktail i
use it as a mixer
like it kind of does it all and it's
just delicious
i mean if that isn't like a ringing
endorsement of why
to drink this i'm drinking the prickly
pear now and it's so beautiful
and i think people um
you know they want sort of guidance and
advice on things to
enjoy in life and i love that you're
leading the way
with this beautiful product and um i'm
just so happy to see you and check in
with you
and i will be more bold out there in the
world in honor of your boldness
and make sure that you all go online um
today and order some cali water we're
gonna feature it on our website but
it's gonna blow up and everybody's gonna
be drinking it and it's gonna be amazing
thank you vanessa so much
it's so wonderful to see you